[Music]
you can you start by clarifying what
exactly Google Cloud I'm sorry what
exactly Twitter is moving to Google
cloud we are migrating our ad hoc and
our cold stores use cases to cloud that
takes about a third of our Hadoop
infrastructure and our project name
partly cloudy
he said ad hoc and called what does that
mean ad hoc is exploratory data analysis
what's called yeah we have different use
cases for different different clusters
for different use cases original data
lands on our T clusters that's where the
original data comes in then ad hoc and
exploratory use cases run on ad hoc
clusters production clusters run the
repeat jobs that run over and over and
over again
those hit on production clusters and our
cold storage is more for data that is
less
accessed and less frequently used is it
fair to say that the production clusters
are batch jobs versus the ad hoc
clusters are kind of like off-the-cuff
jobs yeah most of the jumps on the
Hadoop clusters are batch and it's the
the difference being production and ad
hoc is more that there's the ad hoc is
interactive and less predictable whereas
production jobs are near the repeat jobs
that run over and over and over again
that are more predictable great and I
believe you blogged about this yesterday
as well right yes we have a blog post
out and most of those links will end up
being on clout google.com force less
Twitter so why Google cloud a couple of
years ago we ended up doing a large
evaluation of multiple vendors and you
know we measured many different things
did a lot of benchmarking and
particularly the network capability that
the ability be able to separate stores
from compute and to be able to scale the
compute independently from the storage
those were all deciding factors and one
of the other very large deciding factors
was the technical capabilities and the
interaction with all of the engineers on
the Google side that great partnership
so far cool so before getting into the
details of your Hadoop infrastructure
I'd like to get the audience involved in
our discussion
tweet your question with this hashed
the hashtag will be repeated throughout
the future slides on the bottom left
Hashim who's raising his hand in the
front will be sharing your questions
live from Twitter with us throughout the
panel but also at the end of the panel
where we'll do a dedicated 10 or 15
minutes of Q&A so we won't be using Dory
for this session we'll take the
questions live from Twitter with the
hashtag so let's talk about Hadoop as it
runs at Twitter on Prem at scale right
now so these are pretty massive numbers
500,000 cores more than 10,000 node
clusters Laura can you talk a bit about
the challenges involved with running
Hadoop at this scale so there are
several challenges but I would like to
point out that scalability is like
probably at the very top we whatever
features we implement or any new
infrastructure we plan to build from the
very beginning we consider scalability a
couple of years back when we started off
with our Hadoop clusters we had about
like 2000 node Hadoop clusters and that
at that time the largest known publicly
known Hadoop cluster was about four
thousand knows and our challenge our
target was to build a 6,000 node cluster
so right from HDFS to yarn beat the
applications libraries for example
shared cache whatever features we had to
build we had to think about scalability
and today we have our single largest
clusters or more than 12,500 nodes and
we have multiple of them yeah I mean
that's pretty amazing is that one single
Hadoop cluster one name node that's
serving out 12,500 nodes so that's a
very good question it's actually
multiple dev nodes we could have
anywhere between six to eight named
nodes traditionally the architecture of
HDFS was that a single named node could
not scale so how do community and we
invested a lot of time in Federation
hdfs Federation client-side mountable x'
to make it more scalable to 12,500 hosts
Wow and you are you running a your
hadoop directly from apache or is it a
vendor distribution you can imagine at
our scale we're building our own hadoop
distribution it is very close to apache
so when we were first started with
Hadoop 2 we were one of the earlier ones
to run to o 0 alpha and then we were
with the community there was a newer
release then we leapfrog them and jump
to a 2.2 and etc etc so you know we're
very close to an open-source
distribution maybe a couple of dozen 200
patches difference but very very close
and those are typically patches that'll
go into upstream as well oh yeah I know
you guys are a very major contributor to
open source Hadoop as well so thanks for
that
mashaallah I'm curious about the compute
cores half a million compute cores what
Apache engines are you running there so
in data platform right we support a
bunch of technologies for doing data
processing our production clusters run
scalding jobs so most of our production
workload is all scalding in addition to
scalding what we've seen is people want
to use people want to have different
ways of getting at the data right they
want to use different technologies so we
also have spark I've pressed you on an
ad hoc plus Joseon so variety of them
what about the 300 petabytes of logical
storage mishali what kind of data file
formats are you guys using on HDFS we
have lzo thrift and park a as a main
file formats we also have a few regular
text files I see and you know look this
is something that I found really
interesting when I worked with you guys
on this project there 1.5 trillion
messages a day and even the 300 petabyte
how do you get to one point five
trillion messages a day surely there's
not quite that many tweets per day and
each tweet is only about 280 characters
how does that build up to 300 petabytes
yeah so that that's a very good question
so the actual tweet text itself is a
very small percentage so whenever users
visit twitter.com/rabbischneider
there are a lot of things they're doing
the interactions the timeline that order
of treats they see who to follow
suggestions the search they do so all
these actions generate something called
as events and we collect our framework
is capable of aggregating about 1.5
trillion events every day that's about 1
billion events every minute Wow
yeah this is a massive migration we're
surely can you talk a bit about which
teams were involved to accomplish this
so for the partly-cloudy project it was
not just a Hadoop team at Twitter pretty
much all of the teams in data
infrastructure were involved teams that
on scalding presto at the analytical
data tool tools that we have all of the
libraries and then it wasn't just data
infrastructure we actually work with
several teams at Twitter like the
network engineering team the public
cloud services team the platform
security team and then it was not just
Twitter going at this all alone we
actually work very closely with Google
on this we in fact have an on-site
google presence at Twitter so we have
people from the Google professional
services organization who are on-site at
Twitter working very closely with us I
mean you guys seem like a very competent
Hadoop group why did you decide to
engage Google cloud professional
services on this engagement well we know
how to run the Hadoop clusters
on-premise way you can I mentioned that
as many companies have done over the
past decade we've build a lot of
plumbing and infrastructure when we it's
like the larger twitter twitter
engineering work right so from how we
build services how we deploy them how
would you have configuration
how would you monitoring how would you
alerting all of that infrastructure is
is in place and is build-out for the
infrastructure within our data centers
itself so we know how to run clusters
and how to run services in our own data
centers as we decided to expand that out
to Google cloud and we decided to engage
with the goomar partners to make sure
that you know a much higher chance of
success in making it successful and you
know and through this partnership Google
folks have found out that you know some
of the Twitter cases are slightly
different maybe than what you're used to
and we've made improvements
you know alongside with you guys
and on our side we're trying to just you
know make sure that we do things well on
the cloud site and for users we're
trying to make sure that you know things
are similar as we can so they have the
same experience on-premise as the
wireless and they have in cloud
interesting and surely what are we
looking at here with the work streams
how did you guys decide to organize the
different work streams I suppose so we
had this goal of extending Twitter's
data platform to a hybrid cloud model
right on promises and cloud so in order
to reach this goal we started by
identifying the top broad work stream
areas that were needed to be done in
order to get to this hybrid model and as
each work stream began to evolve you
know we came up with milestones and
those milestones brought forward the
dependencies that existed between the
different components and services that
needed to be completed in order to reach
that milestone and pretty much as we
kept working on this we realized that we
needed a very close collaboration
between all of the teams not just within
Twitter but also with Google to make
this adoption of GCP at Twitter
successful so use the interesting word
you said extending your data
architecture to the cloud does that mean
you're keeping the on-prem clusters and
extending it the feature set to the
cloud or are you fully migrating CERN
Hadoop clusters to the cloud so we are
migrating our ad hoc and our cold data
storage to GCP we are still keeping our
production clusters on-premises so some
of the clusters will continue to remain
on promises and we will have new
clusters like ad hoc clusters that will
come up in GCP I say so here we're
looking at tradition there would be
clusters in both on-premise and cloud so
there will be appeared were both are
alive until the migration is fully
complete and at that point we'll have a
talk Lester's only in cloud interesting
can you walk us through this diagram
we're looking at the partly cloudy
architecture here yeah what we're
looking at here is a little bit of our
target architecture as represented by
the Twitter Birds on your left-hand side
that's all of our users interacting with
the different systems these as low it
said these users it you know generated
all these events that land into our
through our log pipeline on tour
our IT clusters that's what we call the
real-time clusters those clusters also
used to serve some outgoing data sets
and to production servers and then that
data is collected through a locked
pipeline and goes into production
servers this picture shows that our ad
hoc clusters are fully migrated into
cloud is the target architecture and
what we've done here is that we're
separating our storage into GCS so that
all of the the files and objects are
going to be stored in GCS and the
analysis is going to be running on both
Hadoop clusters as well as other tools
we will have presto and other tools that
we will use as well so the ad hoc
cluster has a Google compute engine
Logan logo next to it is that what
you're using to run your ad hoc clusters
yeah the other clusters itself will be
large shared clusters that we're running
on compute instances there's other cases
where we use data proc that's underneath
presto that's an example there's other
examples where we spin up temporary data
proc lustres to load data into bigquery
for example so there's other cases where
those are used I'm Chris to dig into
that a little bit more how did you guys
decide to kind of move your stack from
on-prem as it as it is I suppose to
Google Cloud as opposed to using manage
service like data proc yeah there's the
choice to either have all of data proc
have everything as a managed service and
you can imagine you know when you run a
handful of jobs in a day then using a
cluster per job isn't totally
appropriate situation at our scale Mun
running eighty thousand hundred thousand
hundred fifty thousand jobs in a day if
you were to launch 150,000 clusters in a
day and then have to keep track of who
run what where that becomes very
difficult to do at the same time it was
also very difficult to judge how big
that cluster needs to be so if there's
an ad hoc case users don't necessarily
know ahead of time how big the cluster
needs to be so if they were if everybody
were to launch a 2,000 know cluster then
that would be very inefficient it may be
very low utilization at that point
that's the reason why we're running
larger shared clusters I say
multi-tenant clusters yeah I think
that's a really fair point you're making
about data proc actually last week we
released the GCP broker service to
actually address a integration of data
proc with Kerberos where you can have
multi users within a data proc Lester as
well
I'm also queue
about the Google Cloud storage law what
kind of buckets are you guys using for
GCS so for most part we are using
something called as a dual reagent
buckets where if we load the data into
those buckets from two of the regions
the data will automatically be
replicated and consistently be available
from the two regions not spread across
the entire region
like for example US region or something
I say yeah she misses a question from
Twitter there were a couple of questions
around data proc which I think we answer
but one new question that came up was
how are you thinking about storing tweet
compression data what data models or
tools are you leveraging this is from
cats on Twitter so the question is what
data models are you are we using yes
what data models are tools are you
leveraging so former change from
on-premise to cloud our users are going
to still use the same tools that they're
using on Prem so the the change from
on-premise to cloud is not going to
change this the format or the storage of
how tweets or data is stored that
remains the same yes
most of the data right like so if a
service a new micro service is emitting
some events so they have a well defined
schema associated with that and for the
most part it's like a thrift schema and
then we compress it using l0 so it's
like a l0 thrift format especially toad
and we're talking more about disks are
you using persistent disks as well
unlike the ad hoc cluster because I can
see Google Cloud Storage there
so yes it's a combination of persistent
disk and GCS so what we are first when
we started to evaluate we thought about
options of running just haitch DFS on
those VMs which would be very
inefficient because you need to
replicate like three ways for HDFS so
what we ended up doing was in a
MapReduce generally typically in
analytics pipeline a MapReduce has
multiple stages where output of one
stage gets written to disk and
next stage reads that data does some
processing and then writes a disk again
so for that intermediate stages for fast
access and temporary data we are using
persistent disk but the initial input
and the final output is on GCS I see so
the source of truth is GCS but you use
the persistent disk as like shuffle
space or intermediate job storage J's
and the advantage of that as well as
that we can now use other cloud native
tools to leverage that so people might
use data proc or in some cases bigquery
they can use directly that data from GCS
and we don't have to store them multiple
times I say so I definitely wanna dig a
little bit more into the details here
but before we move on can you talk a
little bit about the log pipeline low
hit like what exactly is happening there
and you're writing to real-time clusters
and then it goes to a production cluster
what exactly is that pipeline look like
good so as I said in the very beginning
the actions users actions actions
generate like a lot of these events so
each of these event has a name
associated with it which ultimately
translates to a data set name so the
lock pipeline is responsible for
aggregating all the events which we live
which we receive from thousands of
different servers aggregate all of them
and then write it as log files on HDFS
usually time partition we do it on an
hourly boundary we also do some
cleansing format conversion depending on
the data set and then we have a
replication framework which takes care
of copying the data from real time
cluster to production or other places I
also do what to mention that that we
call it real time because those are the
clusters which are like the incoming
clusters the uptime on those clusters
are like several years we rarely take
down the cluster do you run any Hadoop
jobs on those worked on clusters we do
not run Hadoop jobs mainly because of
this reason because Hadoop jobs can be
unpredictable depending on like user
actions so it's mostly these clusters
are like incoming clusters to get the
data and then serve some subset of data
sets so you mentioned the data
replicator I'm assuming the derivative
cater is moving the data from
these on-premise clusters between each
other can you talk a little bit about
how it works when you use the data
replicator to move data to the cloud
sure so we already have a well defined
like service data applicator with given
a source and a destination and a data
set it can keep track of changes at the
source and make sure all the data is
synced to the destination whenever new
datasets are arriving source it will
make sure that that data is replicated
so for GCS what we did was we created
something called as a copy cluster which
is like in transit cluster which has
direct connect connectivity to the
Google endpoints and we set up a similar
replicator like how we have for on trim
for cloud also and then said okay source
is our input HDFS cluster and
destination is GCS this is interesting I
mean for the audience members who might
not be familiar with this CP can you
explain what distributed copy is and I'm
kind of curious about why the data is
the data replicator just kind of kicking
off the CP jobs or what is it exactly
doing there sure so see as I said so for
a particular data set we have a
well-defined partitions in this case of
early partitions right I see that in the
year month day hour hours right so this
data set on cluster X so what this what
the data replicator does here is that
for every new hourly partition it sees
at the source it kicks off one DCP job
right so the DCP is our standard
MapReduce application it basically
copies lot of files in parallel taking
advantage of the parallelism offer how
to cluster so if you want to make it go
fast you just throw in more mappers and
then it can copy the data so yeah so
that's that's the recipe is ready the
data and here you can see that the copy
cluster even though it's a Hadoop
cluster
it never saves any data locally it's not
stored in the copy cluster and then
copied to GCS it's a pass-through DCP I
say and
you put it what is Sun sorry Oh shame go
ahead so there's another question around
security but I think we can tackle this
on Presta question which is similar did
you have to make any changes for presto
to work on GCP yes I think that's on the
previous slide so we are running some
pressure clusters in GCP as well we had
to make some changes to presto and those
changes were basically required because
we wanted to follow our triple-a design
principles so Triple A meaning
authentication authorization and
auditing so authentication is when you
know users identify themselves as who
they are so if a user says let's say I
say I'm Raja Lee I need to identify
myself let's say with my driver's
license or something I should be able to
say Who I am right that is
authentication authorization is when we
want to make sure that users can
actually access the data that they are
trying to access so are they authorized
to access that data and auditing is when
we want to know who accessed which data
set when and we wanted to have a very
clear-cut way of determining that so
those three Triple A design principles
are made us make some changes to
pressroom
interesting and presto has a data proc
logo next to is that what you guys are
using right now to run presto yes that
is good idea okay
can you talk a little bit about the
scale that you guys have benchmarked or
tested presto and Google Cloud so we've
we've run our data profit about presto
with about 90,000 of course yeah that's
interesting because I think that's the
largest data processor that has ever
been launched as far as I know for for
public customers before we move on into
a little my beer will launch more alerts
cluster soon okay well you'll beat your
own record very soon then before we move
away from the data replication slide low
heck I'm curious also about the 800
gigabits I mean that's a very fat
network pipe to say the least how is
that Network configured how do you
handle security around that curious yeah
so when we decided to
set up these copy replication from our
on-prem hadoop clusters to GCSE right so
what we decided was the data there are
some metadata operations which the
return data replicator or services has
to do to say look up the source and
destination directory make sure like all
the files are there or not those are
like metadata operations but the actual
bulk transfer the data transfer would be
like in the order of like petabytes of
data right so our network engineers what
they with Google folks what they ended
up doing is to do like a Twitter Google
pni set up private interconnect between
us and we our provider 800 gigabits per
second bandwidth now all the nodes in
the copy cluster have direct access to
the GCS endpoints is that what the
orange thing is so the orange thing is a
very interesting stuff so that is the
Google how do connector so how do file
system is like an abstract file system
HDFS is in fact just an implementation
of that interface so what Google ended
up doing was they implemented the same
interface so any API filesystem API
calls would be automatically translated
to the Google Cloud Storage API using
that connector it's like a library so
the advantage now is that any
application which is using the Hadoop
api's don't need to change anything so
they can interact with Google Cloud
Storage as if it's like any other Hadoop
storage so for most part we didn't have
to make any code changes in the data
replicator so we just plugged it in and
then TCP would just work sure I
definitely want to come back to the GCS
connector again I know that there are
some really interesting developments
that happened in GCS connector because
of the Twitter project but before I move
away from this slide you I'm curious
800 gigabit that's a fat pipe like I
said before so that means like I did I
just have math before this talk one
petabyte you can move in just under
three hours so 300 petabytes would be
about 35 days
if you have the pipe running at full
stream with that in mind how long is
this data migration project taking we've
done some modeling and if you were to go
full bore and pump it across it would
take about four months keep in mind that
this data is not a static data set
either right so new new piece of
information keep coming in and in the
days of privacy and data protection and
GDP are regulations some of these data
sets are also getting scrubbed so it
used to be that for example an hour
worth of tweets was written once and
would never be changed but we would
consider to be very cold datasets the
written ones and only the new hours are
coming in as you have a right to be
forgotten and those kind of
functionalities have to be implemented
some of these petitions actually get
rewritten so as as the time goes by as
you're copying data and as it
progressing some of this data is
changing and is modifying so the way
we're setting this up and the reason why
we have a copy cluster is that that is
also providing some funneling where we
can do prioritization the latest are
working to be copied first and then in
the in the in the valley of the you know
during the peak you have the new hour
that of data that comes in and in the
valley whether the network traffic is is
less utilized we can do the backfill
part I say Shirley can you give us just
a sense of how many data sets are
involved that you have on-premise at
Twitter and is this all moving to one
massive GCS bucket so when we were
thinking of how to move this data set on
HDFS you know into GCS we had a few
different options right either we could
just put everything in one bucket and
have everybody access it but then that
doesn't sound very good right so we had
the other option of trying to group
together datasets and put them in you
know some some buckets but then the
model that we picked was going with a
data set ownership model so every data
set owner a poor data set owner we
create one bucket and that is what we
ended up with how many data sets are
there about hundreds of data sets close
mm I mean thousand observe yeah and how
do you organize your architecture within
Google Cloud so for organizing these
buckets right we wanted to think about
how we want to put them in projects
either we could put them again in one
project and have everybody just run all
of their resource
there but then at our scale that becomes
too big and unwieldy
so then we thought about going you know
the other extreme that would be having
one project per small application but
again at our scale that becomes too big
to manage so we pick a middle ground and
we said okay let's have a one project
poor business unit so for example for
Twitter infrastructure engineering we
have one GCP project for twitter revenue
we have one so that way we have a few
handful of projects that we can manage
and then we organize our buckets within
those projects so having a few projects
does give us some delineation some
boundaries between what we want to do
across these projects but then I we have
a few of them to manage not too many or
just one sure I mean so you've I
understand the scope of these projects
there's like billing scopes and perhaps
security scopes but what exactly is in
these projects I see like a Hadoop logo
and a GCS bucket so how many Hadoop
clusters are running in these projects
and how many GCS buckets are on these
projects yeah like I said the the the
project is a delineation and is a
security boundary as well so within each
project we're running 100 cluster that
are shared and this is again done for
fragmentation purposes if you had one
very large cluster there would be great
form fragmentation perspective because
all the users been packed very well
together if you were to go to the very
other extreme where you run one cluster
per job you have a huge amount of
fragmentation and whenever the cluster
is not fully used that's gonna sit
around idle so we chose the middle
ground where we end up delineating and
saying one cluster for each of these
pillar projects or pillar organizations
we call them and then all of the buckets
that are that belong to all of the users
that are in that pillar organization
fall along those lines so there will be
a set of buckets for each user there
will be set of buckets for each log
category and to clarify when we think of
datasets they're sort of roughly two
sets of data sets that were thinking of
you have the initial log categories and
that's an automated intuitive a thousand
and you have about a thousand individual
users or a magnitude of that and they
each have you know dozens of their own
data sets so the total number of data
sets is fairly large if you think of the
incoming log categories that allow it
explained that's
a magnitude of a thousand so it'll be
several thousand buckets for each of
these projects interesting so Shelley I
want to go back to the triple a I think
we said authentication authorization and
auditing I'm gonna go back to that and
think about that a little bit so
authentication I think that's just a
user says they are who they are
authorization you got to give them
permission to do something and finally
auditing can you talk a little bit about
that in respect to how you set up your
security model and user permissions for
Hadoop right so let's start by
understanding how users do their work on
premises and and in GCP right so we have
users that's the blue blue figure there
so every user has a UNIX account right
that that they use to run their day to
day on promise jobs you know on in
cluster whatever work they need to do
now this user also has AG suite account
that they use for their email the Google
Docs sheets or all of that work now when
we look think about a process running
right the process runs as a UNIX user
now that process needs to read data or
write dry to GCS now in order to do that
it needs to have the right permissions
one way is one way to access the data in
GCS is yrg suite but then that means
that you need to provision the G suite
credentials
on the VM node right we did not want to
do that so the pig wire so we do not
want to provision the G suite
credentials on a particular VM because a
person who has admin privileges on the
VM then can act as that user so then
that person would have access to their G
suite Google Docs Gmail all of that
right so on the VMS we provision a
shadow account for what we call as a
shadow account per user what is a
sharing so a shadow account is nothing
but a Google service account a Google
service account that exists in GCP and
there is one GCP account one GCP service
account per UNIX user
and a Google service account has a set
of keys associated with it and those
keys and that account is provisioned on
those VMs so that way you only have that
account that and the key that is
existing on that node but it is
transparent to the user themselves when
they're running a job think of this when
you park your car and you come and you
have valet parking when you hand over
your key you know you may not want the
the person parking your car be able to
get into your glove compartment but this
is actually in one step further if you
want to also be able to say well this
person can drive your car and can drive
slow but they cannot drive to the
freeway and they can drive around but
they cannot have a party in the back
that's not okay so this essentially is a
different set of keys that provides you
subsets of functionality that act a
little bit as the user but not in all
particular accounts so when when Hadoop
cluster runs a jump under my credentials
and load as an administrator he can see
the the tasks running but he cannot
access my Google account on Gmail or in
my Google Drive
these are just normal Google service
accounts it sounds like you're
multiplexing them within the same
cluster to some extent you're sharing
many of them within the same cluster so
there is one Google service account Perl
UNIX user per user and only that UNIX
user can read the keys or access the
keys of that service account
you know you that sounds like a security
flaw I mean if you have one service
account per user what if that gets
compromised keys keys getting
compromised is always a bad situation in
this case it's actually better if a key
gets compromised to have the shedder key
compromised because then the user can
access only GCS and not their G suite
account in addition to that we end up
rotating these keys so it becomes a
little bit easier this is transparent
for each individual user so I'm gonna
user logs in or SSH into a box and the
access and Hadoop cluster or the X's GCS
transparently behind the scenes the
shedder account keys are being leveraged
and those keys can rotate over time and
they're valid only for a few days that
is much simpler than their G suite
account keys or other keys that may if
they live longer and that users to be
aware of so okay just stepping back
Laura can you walk me through the user
experience imagine I'm a engineer
Twitter I want to submit a Hadoop job
and now I want to submit it to Google
Cloud how is my user experience
different like what am i doing am ia
searching into something new am i
submitting it through a browser like how
do I actually submit a Hadoop job once
Twitter is in Google Cloud so that's a
very good question
so most of the like the foundational
stuff which we have build a we have been
building is to make sure that like users
have a uniform way of accessing the
stuff in GCS just like how they do
internally so what we ended up doing in
this particular case is that we created
something called us jump hosts or we
call like nest boxes where users log in
using their like UNIX account once they
log into that box automatically be
provisioned their shadow accounts JSON
key only for them it will be accessible
only for them using which they can
access any of the GCP resources along
with that some of the resources we also
provision there g-suit permissions to
access some data so if there are tools
such as bigquery where they have to
access it from UI so since the access to
the data and the tables in this case
have been granted permission they will
be access able to access either by a web
browser or this jump hosts one last
question
I mean before we go to a shame who who
seems to there's another question from
the audience
but before they you mentioned a nest box
you assistant to the nest box you submit
the job on-premise I'm assuming it's the
same thing so you're saying the user
experience is kind of very similar
exactly so you the same tools which
users are used on Prem they are made
available on those next nest boxes as
well but what about like GCS right so
can use your still access GCS through
the Google Cloud console through the web
browser yes they can and they can also
use the as I mentioned earlier there is
this google hadoop connector so using
that we have created mappings for the
users so just like they access HDFS
using Hadoop commands and then a
well-defined path we have created a new
moon point for the GCS to say slash
ECS and then any part within HDFS name
node name it's just G CGS I believe yes
sir it's kind of transparent exactly
Shane if you have a question there are
two last questions before before we open
up to the floor later first since
McQuarrie came up did you think of
replacing parts or all of your Hadoop
cluster with bigquery and BigTable short
answers yes you're thinking we'll
probably have a combination of both
just some use cases that will be more
appropriate and bigquery other cases
Christo is more appropriate for us and
all the cases users are still using
Hadoop to run their jobs because they're
doing analysis and then later on they
will run that same job in production you
how do you users decide if they want to
run a sequel query through presto or
spark or hive the exact details of how
we're going to decide between all of the
various cases we're gonna still
determine and we're doing an earlier
alpha test mode know with some of our
users and you know we're gonna find out
you know what the most appropriate tool
is from online as this must cost a ton
do you have any tips to take advantage
of how to keep the costs under control
particularly with regards to data proc
and GCS I think being in the cloud model
bring in GC GCP right there are a lot of
advantages to that rather than looking
at just the cost if you look at the
advantages that we get by Google's
networking setup the fact that we can
separate compute and storage right all
of those advantages add up so it's
really difficult to say whether we are
focusing on the storage cost versus all
of these other advantages that we are
getting this is also one of the reasons
why we're running a larger shared Hadoop
cluster where individual jobs can
interleave together so if there's a job
as there's multiple stages of a
MapReduce job and the jobs for example
at a stage but a single reducer the
cluster is not going to sit around idle
because other users will use that same
cluster we're not you know being able to
very closely monitor which users use
which resources and we have a mapping
and at the end our users are gonna be
responsible our engineers are
responsible to make sure that they use
the tools in an appropriate manner this
is the same as what we do on premise
sometimes users will run jobs now we see
sometimes see jobs that are running
300,000 mappers and 200,000 reducers
this can happen and it's a balance
between making as simple as we can for
users to use and not have to think about
it and at the same time you know if the
cost becomes very high then users have
to rationalize and think through look is
this the most appropriate thing to do
for a business and they make that choice
you mentioned something that I think is
worth diving a little bit more into you
mentioned separation of compute from
storage which is not what you learn
about when you read like Hadoop the
definitive God the whole idea of Hadoop
is to keep storage close to compute
there's many benefits there like the map
tasks can start near where one of the
three replicas of the data block is when
you separated out Hadoop at your skill
separated out storage on to GCS and then
separated Li run I ran Hadoop clusters I
mean I think can you share more about
your thinking there and around any
challenges you ran into and you did
something at that scale and I'm also
curious like when you store something in
GCS can one who do cluster read from
that can many Hadoop clusters read from
that and just talk about the pros and
cons about that well I'll answer the
second question first because that's the
simpler one in the first question I hand
over to Lily yes one of the reasons why
we store data in GCS is because then it
can be shared across multiple users if
they have the appropriate access so
there's excess models around that um so
you know data stored in GCS can be used
by multiple users from various clusters
that's the one mechanism how to share
across many projects or one GCS bucket
can serve two external projects as well
that's right so that goes back to I
think this slide where you have one GCS
in like Twitter product but the revenue
team can read from that if permissions
are scoped current IC and so Laura can
you talk more about that that decision
to separate compute from storage around
any technical challenges you saw there
so C traditionally like HDFS but it
became very popular over the last decade
right so the
local compute was the key like basically
you wherever the data is you send your
compute there to be more efficient and
over the years what happened was like
you build these large clusters say two
thousand five thousand node clusters and
if you need more compute there was no
option no other option other than either
changing your machine configuration or
adding extra nodes with more anyways so
that model kind of like changed
altogether when the storage and the
compute could be now separated
independently right so for example one
example is that we tend to replicate the
same data set across multiple different
clusters based on use cases right
but with the storage system such as GCS
you just store one copy and then
multiple compute instances can
independently access them so there is
definitely a bit of performance
difference but for most part when you
factor in like how the network is laid
out in GCP and how you are caching and
how we are organizing your jobs it kinds
of like adds up I say
you saw no performance degradations in
doing that type of separation for most
of the batch analytics when we did the
performance evaluation last year Derek
and Dave also shared a lot of
information about that in the Google X
so for most part we saw very consistent
performance from GCP and then it was
almost one is to one Wow I definitely
want to plug Derek Lyons talk on YouTube
about this as well you guys did a very
sophisticated analysis with like grid
max and Terrigen to understand your your
your synthetic simulation use cases
within Google Cloud so definitely do a
youtube search on that so before we take
questions from the audience I want to
talk a bit about the new tools or Google
cloud platform improvements that were
needed to support this migration Laura
can you talk about the data retention
for example sure
so GC has already provided like object
likes lifecycle management tools to
manage your data to automatically delete
it based on say creation create time or
something right so but for us it is much
more complicated as I mentioned earlier
we have data sets which have like an
hourly partition and users usually
configure complex potential tools such
as any data which is older than say 30
days needs to be deleted automatically
and that decision happens based on the
path of the data set not the actual
create time or modification time it's
derived out of the path of the
particular data set because there are
cases where we could backfill we could
copy the entire data set to destination
cluster or we could scrub the data to
make some changes so such a
functionality was not available on GCS
so with Google engineers that is now an
open source tool called
sdrs supplementally supplementary data
retention service which is also open
source which kind of does a similar
thing on GCP as well where is an open
source at its own github google google
arm ok so I'm trying to understand a
little bit more around this you're
saying object lifecycle management in
GCS indeed works on object creation time
you showed us hourly time partitioned
data sets before you're saying those are
like event times event of what event
event the tweet took place so those are
the times on which that message got
created on the real time on the real
time so that's time-stamped and you want
to expire data based on that time not
the object creation time in case there's
delays on the log pipeline I'm guessing
that is right so as I said when we copy
the data from our HDFS cluster like
let's say take an example of initials
copy write the seed copy we would copies
like few months of data onto GCS there
we cannot set oil and policy saying that
anything older than 30 days get rid of
it exactly that that is the reason why
we had to come up with stool interesting
what about demigods were Charlotte
that's a
interesting sounding name many gods what
is that say demigod is basically a group
of services that we use to configure
Twitter's GCP platform for partly cloudy
the name demigod comes from the fact
that you know these are admin services
these are admin processes but they have
privileges that are exactly scope to
whatever they need to do so it's like a
demigod it it's a god-like service but
not quite with all of the admin
privileges but only that which what it
needs to do what do they do though they
have semi admin privileges what do they
do
so these these services are responsible
for creating buckets creating shadow
accounts granting I am policies on
packets you know key management all that
oh interesting so provisioning those
service accounts that we talked about
earlier or making these hundreds or
thousands of GCS a bucket it sounds like
automation tools yes so these are
automated tools that Google that we have
or that are running on GCP these are
driven these are event-driven services
so for example when users join LDAP
groups or when we make config changes to
our files that's when these services
could get triggered and they run and
then they reset the state of the system
to what it's expected to be so if
somebody makes a manual change on a
bucket the demigod service will go and
reset the state to whatever it should be
interesting what about the bucket move
rename tool so as we were working with
buckets and you know getting familiar
with GCP we realized that we needed the
ability to move buckets across projects
or to change the name of buckets now we
wanted to work with buckets as we were
working on our design right
that is when we wanted a tool from
Google and we put for this request to
Google and they built an open-source
tool it's on github as well I am so it
can move buckets across projects it can
rename them there are several
configuration options that it takes yeah
feel free to look it up and that's on
github I believe for Google cloud
platform as well I think that's a really
useful tool
GCS buckets are globally namespace try
so I think you have to have just one
name so I'm guessing
tool just something like deletes that
name and stores the data temporarily
then recreates that name in a different
project and just moves it over yes so so
this tool basically creates a temporary
swap bucket it first copies over all of
the data and when it starts that it
actually locks the incoming bucket so
that you don't keep making changes there
and then once that all of the data has
been copied over it will delete this
bucket and then recreate the same bucket
in a different project or with a
different name and then copy over the
data from the temporary bucket into that
that's not super useful you can you tell
us a little bit about the HDFS to GCS
checksum feature this one feature that
we added in collaboration with Google in
order to make sure that the check sums
match all the way from the source all
the way through to the target the
checksumming mechanism in HDFS is
different than in GCS and this is a
feature that's been added HDFS site to
make sure that the checksums can check
all the way through from end to end very
cool and I believe this work was
actually done in open source Apache HDFS
correct yes initially one of my team
members implemented this first and is
running that because not all of our
cluster have been upgraded to that
version yet and then worked with Google
engineers and has done in open source
yes we recall and finally you can you
tell us a little bit about GCS connected
to data performance improvements I
should tell let the audience know that
in the next week or two of you are gonna
increment the version of GCS connector
from one dot X to 2.0 and there's a
couple of dozen major improvements in
there a lot of which were driven by the
Twitter project can you tell us a little
bit about some of that yep
yeah one of the features has been added
is this cooperative locking mechanism
feature where you can imagine an object
store function is very different than a
file system in an object store there's
no such thing as an inode where
directories are a first-class citizen
so as items move around it's possible
that you know people move directories so
it locks a directory I suppose before it
it methide that directory
yep a locust Eakins are the multiple
users moving around directories I
believe this is an alpha stage right now
but it should be coming out very soon
all right so to start wrapping up you
can tell us a little bit about this
special URL that you talked about
the very beginning yeah Google's is
hosting a peach on on cloud.google.com
forceless twitter will be you know
hosting a list of links there and
resources and things that we're working
on together and collaborating on and
we're working on a series of blog posts
so those will be linking there as well
and you know other talks will be linked
there so people want to fall along and
collaborate with us on these projects
they can you can find all this
information over there : yeah I would
love to see a lot more of the details of
what you guys are doing in the next year
or so I didn't want to give a plug to a
few upcoming Twitter talks next in the
next couple of days so take a quick
screenshot of this if you guys are
interested and for the live Q&A check
out Twitter
[Music]